so i love quotes especially the
lesser-known ones and i'd like to share
some of those with you in one of my
favorite segments that we call quotables
oh uh let's look at this first one this
is quote i just scored blow
that's attributed to a composer for the
movie blow
some of you thought it was cocaine he
bought
some of you thought it meant i just
bought some cocaine these are street
terms
let's look at this next one uh quote
i've got georgia on my mind that's a
real one from ray charles
quote who the is georgia that's ray
charles's wife
trouble they're having trouble
this one is very stupid quote
our bees
that is a pirate getting attacked by
yellow jackets in a roast beef
restaurant okay
because
something a pirate might say and also
he's in
a i wrote that one
i how did that get in i wrote it
quote these improv classes are really
starting to pay
off that's a guy who just robbed
everyone in his improv house
it's the first time that's ever been
said
quote hey uh small note um can you make
the dots not taste like
that's pac-man complaining to the
inventor of pac-man
it's just not necessary
give him a light flavoring
quote
the question my friend is blowing in the
wind
anyone have a guess
it's bob dylan on jeopardy
was your guest funnier
if it was just stick with that
quote
walk past the snow shoes and make a
right at the frame picture of elf if you
see mr peanut you've gone too
far that's just a waiter at tgi fridays
giving directions to the bathroom
ladies go laughs at the picture of al
quote
but then what did i just
do that one is a post-coital aquaman
learning there's no such thing as
mermaids
it's just something
that's quotables everyone
you